now devonte adams are going to hear from
him in a second he said that matt
lafleur addressed everything with the
team the elephant in the room was not
ignored the way that some other coaches
may be tempted to do it
because this is the mvp of the nfl he's
not there everyone knows about it and
with him not there to talk about it
others are going to be talking about it
including devante adams let's hear some
of what he had to say yesterday about
his missing quarterback
any thought that using your power
persuasion to aaron and saying hey
whatever the hell is going on with you
in the organization let's just
let's just come back for one more year
then we'll figure out 2022 um at that
time
i mean it's easier said than done i can
say that that's obviously the
the the morale that i come with that's
that's the type of message i want to
send to him but
you know it's so much that goes into it
you know that once again that's
that's positive a very positive outlook
but it also can be viewed as selfish and
i don't want to put any pressure on
anybody that would be in that situation
let alone um you know aaron rodgers so
we're going to let him
figure it out and you know i'm sure he's
already thinking of course i want to
play with tay so
i'm not saying anything that's probably
not always already on his mind
so at this point it's just going gonna
come down to the logistics and um you
know him and the the rest of the club
kind of ironing out whatever they have
to figure out and none of that's uh on
me and i really don't know as much as
what you guys probably think about it
too so just let that let them handle
that and you know that's that's nothing
for me i got my own stuff to be worrying
about so um you know obviously worry
about you know missing my quarterback
potentially but as far as really ironing
out and you know do this or do that
that's that's not really my place people
that know him well know that he just he
loves you when you have his back so i
mean that's that's how i am naturally so
it's not forced but
um i got his back through everything so
he knows at the end of the day if he if
if he's ever a wonder of you know he's
lost a teammate or something because of
all this come out like he knows where i
stand going back to the i forgot who
asked the question about if it was
awkward
it could never be awkward because i
think that
any gm any president any owner they
should
want type of guys that are you know
backing their players especially a
player like that
you may have seen a couple of white
flashes while he was talking there was
no lightning happening at lambeau field
those were edits made by the packers
because one of the things that adams
said that was edited by the packers was
i'll stand on the
effing mountain and scream on the
mountaintop that i've got his back and
he said the full word instead of
bleeping the word they just dropped that
that sentence that passage yeah but i'll
stand on the effing mountain and scream
on the mountaintop that i've got his
back and
look that that's
that's the dilemma that's created for
the teammates you've got the back of the
the quarterback and you just hope that
the organization understands
that you're gonna support your guy and
so if my guy is upset
i'm i'm on his side i'm on team 12 right
and sorry
goody koon sorry murphy sorry coach i'm
i'm supporting number 12. and i think a
lot of guys are going to feel that way
yeah no no question they are and you
know to your point too with like guten
coost mark murphy whoever it is up in
the front office they understand that
and look and you know really devante
adams again just to shows what what kind
of professional he is i mean he just he
says the right thing his messaging's
perfect he he's yeah i'm on aaron
rodgers side but he says nothing
disrespectful about anybody else and he
understands not to get involved in the
business again it's you know the nfl
it's hey aaron rodgers the king of the
team these players aren't going to mess
with him there is a pecking order there
in that way and everything like that so
you know that the aspect of knowing in
an nfl locker room don't get another
guy's business in the locker room right
it's not your place you just do your job
you worry about wide receiver so i mean
he sends the right message not only to
aaron rodgers the front office but the
guys in the locker room and everything
like that and he's in a tough spot too i
mean he is he like lefleur he's got
something to balance there as well
because devonte adams of course is like
yeah he wants rogers he knows his career
is better with rogers we've talked about
how it's not easy to find that type of
connection he has with aaron rodgers i
mean they have a thing where it's like
you know they can look at each other i
bet you and know like oh the guy's
playing like this rogers is going to
want me to run the route like that i
mean or run this route or whatever that
that is not easy to come by so there's
that devonta adams wants to make sure he
keeps that going let alone hey you know
if he keeps on the current pace
you know he he's underpaid as a wide
receiver he's going to want a new
contract so he's certainly not going to
want to piss off the front office or say
anything that you know is mean or or
disrespectful to them too so he's in a
tough spot but a real professional and i
thought he handled that just about
perfectly
i i thought he did as well and adding to
this
you know everything you said
is spot on yeah
and when you're talking about
a guy with a well-earned and
long-standing reputation of being
prickly
of being sensitive
it raises the stakes
because when you're trying to thread
that needle and keep everybody happy you
have to account for the possibility you
accidentally say something that gets
misinterpreted in some way as a slight
when you weren't even trying to do that
i mean that's one of the realities of
dealing with someone like aaron rodgers
you got to tiptoe around all the time
because you know it's the truth i'm
sorry it's not like it's not like the
bridge between aaron rodgers and me is
going to get any more burn than it is
but the reality is and we all know
people like this
in our lives and if we don't then you
are that person where everyone's got to
tiptoe around everyone's got to be
careful oh you don't know what jim's
going to say about this or that or oh
well you can't say that don't say that
don't even hint at that you know you got
what right am i that guy no i'm actually
as you're saying and i'm going i wonder
if i'm that that guy to my family i
might be that guy i don't know
you're only that guy when there's a
technical issue
then you instantly become that guy it's
like a superpower it's like some weird
transmogrification of
of chris sims to the incredible
technology hating hulk that's what you
become
you are nothing like you otherwise are
the rest of your life until anything
goes wrong technologically then you
become this giant ass i do yes i love
you but it's true that is true i can't
deny that anyway yeah but devonte adams
contract last year this is it right
12.25 million woefully underpaid and
yeah you want the front office to be
happy and you want the guys going to be
throwing you the footballs happy and you
know what i think that
i i who knows what what aaron rodgers
has intimated to any of these guys but
i i i don't know it's even more
important to tiptoe on eggshells if you
think he's coming back i think adam's
based on the way that i heard it i think
he thinks he's coming back yeah i do too
exactly and i think that's why he
answers the question the way he does and
i got his back and you know the the the
scrubbed out quote that you know he uses
the bad word for everything like that
he's making it sure you know he's he's
expecting yeah i think he's gonna be
back and
and uh i got his back because he wants
to hit the ground running like he did
last year certainly doesn't want to deal
with like what you're talking about
drama or having to have a conversation
with rogers because he said something i
didn't mean to say it this way or
whatever so yes uh i thought he
approached it that way too mike that's
something that i definitely was going to
bring up that he approached it like i
think the guy we're going to see him in
a month and we'll see and you know again
here with devonte adams
and you know we talk about the tiptoe
the balance of you know the the players
have you know between okay i want to be
respectful of rogers he's the man in the
locker room you know that's the way an
nfl locker room works i don't want to be
disrespectful to the front office i want
to be careful that you know i don't say
anything bad about them you know but
also like in an nfl locker room
man like
the the i can't even imagine the
conversations that are going on in there
right now but like i'm trying to like in
my own career it would have been similar
to like
it's like with the tampa bay buccaneers
it's a year or two after they've won the
super bowl derrick brooks is still one
of the best linebackers in football we
drafted another linebacker to replace
him it would be constant conversation
about that in the locker room i mean
especially when it happened that's why i
don't think you're ever going to see
anybody totally disrespect rogers on the
roster either letting alone know he's
going to come back but like in the nfl
player world when something like that
happens like i bet you those packers
players that night of the draft were
like
what
like what and they were texting each
other like can you believe this they're
doing this to rogers they're doing this
to rogers and i bet you they were having
like
faces and saying things like that all
year last year so
it's again they're aware of the personal
side from rogers the business side with
the front office but it's just unheard
of kind of in the hierarchy of the nfl
locker room for the king to kind of be
replaced this way and i think they
expect drama when they see that type of
thing i guess is what my point i'm
finally getting to there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports